[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un conte moi quand kulik et une pile de
gêne à dire le plus difficile c'est de
trouver le bon café situé à paris tu vas
marque de respect tu es l et pertinents
ho ho ho eng rayak à vous répéter
toujours la même chose vous faites
macérer un peu moi c'est une insulte
obraniak à titus tu vas me demander
pardon au genou à genou
un voeu nous moi jamais j'aimerais mieux
mourir debout quoi
wade obéissent à 1000 coups de bâton
ceci cela a frappé deux vous ne m'aurez
pas défaut et fond sur mes talents ils
n'ont pas fait et ne voulons pas faite
aux se confondent les vides
je suis sauvé il me faut me bats je vais
la finir moi même j'ai couru moelleux
graïa cas je suis pisier je suis trop
bas tout le monde me trompe ici personne
n'est exécuté mes ordres
mais ça va salle j et tout de suite
yep je comprends qu est-ce qui fait n'a
sûrement jamais sp dié ce qu'offre je me
plie le voir ici
moi c'est moi qui vais le chercher et
titus wam émeutiers
[Musique]
mais bien envie d'aller respirer
ailleurs vais tout sauf qu offre le
grand yaka renvoi pour surveiller
d'expédition de ce pas voyons comment
faut-il procéder
il est volumineux mais facile à
transporter est il solide
oui mon gars tu le fais tu dans ce cadre
c'est ma cassette mais vous voudrez bien
en sortir et ça paie au grand hyatt à
l'eswc à faire je vais me débarrasser de
ces du niveau ceci cela voici mes
instructions
aller chercher une corde pour ficeler
jaffres titus ils sont partis aux homos
ce cas votre remercie vue peur d'être
expédiés dans ce coffre dépêcha de
sortir de là ceci et cela
ils vont revenir
hello grand iata il me cherche tous vous
il est épuisé il s'est endormi sur son
os troicki 6-1
merci mosca vevey dans le jardin j'ai
besoin de prendre l'air alors il tenait
jamais des mots star nous allons les
expédier voilà une chose bien agréable à
faire et en os
soyez sans les petits frères vous allez
faire un beau voyage comme en wagons
lits nous voilà bien tranquille mosca
avec toi je suis toujours tranquille
titus qui tue en voiture on démarre et
et moi je suis toujours debout et pas
avec nous et après après c'est une autre
histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]